bonsoir kiosque votre émission a
culturelle au sommaire ce soir la 14e
édition de la Fête du conte à 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est jusqu'au 6 décembre et
c'est proposé par le réseau des
médiathèques une exposition dédiée à la
céramique en ce moment à la Galerie Le
cambusier de Trappes quatre artistes
exposent leurs œuvres la chronique de
Nicolas Gervais sera consacré à la
chanteuse de jazz agak iraséma en
concert à l'estaminet de Manille aller à
Meaux voilà pour le menu culturel du
kiosque de ce mercredi 19 novembre
du 22 novembre au 6 décembre c'est la
14e fête du conte une manifestation
proposée par le réseau des médiathèques
57 spectacles proposés animations
proposées et pour en parler en plateau
rythme ce soir Cécile pardon Ferraton
bonsoir vous êtes responsable du service
jeunesse à la médiathèque du canal de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à vos côtés Joël
biata bonsoir vous êtes compteuse
décompteurs de Trappes
Cécile quel est le but de cette de cette
fête du conte alors le but en fait c'est
de rassembler sur l'ensemble du réseau
des médiathèques en fait de rassembler à
la fois les tout-petits et les grands
autour du conte qui est une des formes
justement qui rassemble le plus de monde
et qui est transmis même de manière
informelle dans les familles vous dites
les tout-petits et les grands mais ce
sont des comptes pour enfants il y a pas
de compte pour adultes non mais par
contre il y a des veillées ou des
spectacles qui sont familiales et donc
là justement petit et parents sont les
bienvenus justement pour créer un peu
cette atmosphère de partage vraiment
c'est pas réservé aux enfants voilà
c'est
mais c'est quand même malgré tout des
moments forts à retenir ou des
nouveautés cette année alors
en particulier les veillées comptes donc
ils sont proposés dans plusieurs des
médiathèques du réseau donc soit sur une
thématique particulière donc comme la
gourmandise où effectivement sinon qui
accueille en fait des compteurs
professionnels et là aussi pour un
moment de partage partage en famille
effectivement donc il y a principalement
des vendredis soirs vendredi et mardi
soir donc ils sont proposés dans les
médiathèques ou dans des établissements
et des structures partenaires en fait du
réseau des médiathèques il y a aussi le
samedi des mômes oui alors ça c'est
proposé par la médiathèque des 7 Mares
et donc là ça va être organisé cette
année autour d'une déambulation comptée
en fait dans des lieux qui sont autour
de la la bibliothèque des 7 mars et qui
sont proposés par un compteur
professionnel qui est lié à la Maison du
comte de Chevilly-Larue qui est un de
nos partenaires de cet année en fait
alors le justice de cette année aussi
c'est de mettre en avant sur le devant
de la scène des compteurs qui sont des
compteurs locaux et donc il y a une
mobilisation à la fois de compteur
professionnel de compteur amateurs et de
syncontinois les 5 continents peuvent
aussi compter oui c'est ça en fait c'est
une des nouveautés de cette année où on
a souhaité mettre en avant moi aussi des
pratiques qui se font peut-être au sein
de la famille mais de manière un peu
plus formelle lors de rendez-vous donc
ça se passera dans plusieurs
médiathèques du réseau là aussi
principalement sur des samedis matins où
là en fait on invite les parents à venir
compter avec leurs enfants ou à d'autres
personnes qui pourraient être là et là
on accueille vraiment tout le monde pas
uniquement des gens qui ont déjà une
habitude vraiment tout le monde peut
venir pour essayer de compter aussi on
n'est pas des voilà effectivement donc
l'idée c'est effectivement que chacun
puisse se lancer on peut venir avec son
livre voilà venir avec pour raconter aux
personnes qui sont là et puis pour
partager avec les bibliothécaires
également qui sont qui seront présents
alors parmi les compteurs locaux qui
sont présents
vous êtes connu sur l'agglomération puis
depuis 7 ans vous avez intégré des
conteurs de Trappes comment vous allez
vous intervenir pendant cette fête du
conte
alors il y a plusieurs spectacles
auxquels ont participé les compteurs de
trap d'une part
dans la à l'école de musique et de danse
de Trappes ou nous allons raconter des
histoires un petit peu autour du voyage
l'après-midi et le soir si je me trompe
pas c'est le 26 novembre
nous allons raconter aussi des histoires
dans la médiathèque
Jean Jaurès
aussi à la médiathèque Aimé Césaire de
la verrière
je crois aussi qu'il y a une auquel je
ne participe pas mais il y a une une
manifestation aux prismes autour de
Nasreddine voilà donc c'est assez varié
en quoi le compte c'est important ce
qu'on dit c'est important de raconter
des histoires aux enfants mais pourquoi
c'est important de raconter des
histoires aux enfants c'est important
parce que alors d'abord c'est du plaisir
pour eux ils adorent écouter les
histoires
ils partent il voyage dans l'imaginaire
et à l'heure où les enfants sont
abreuvés d'images
télévisuelles jeux vidéo etc et ben là
c'est leur propre imaginaire qui
travaille donc c'est très important
c'est aussi un outil pédagogique parce
que avec le compte ils écoutent
ils se concentrent et
ça les aide à l'apprentissage du langage
et puis je reviens au plaisir il y a le
plaisir de partager quelque chose avec
le compteur ou la conteuse c'est un
moment de communication et d'échanges
après
on pourrait dire que c'est une école de
la vie aussi c'est à dire que si on
prend les contes merveilleux
on parle dans les contes merveilleux des
difficultés dans la famille entre
mère-fille entre père
on peut aborder pratiquement tous les
thèmes oui tous les thèmes alors
évidemment il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
thèmes mais je vais continuer sur ce que
parce que je pense que c'est important
donc tous ces comment dirais-je
toutes ces difficultés qu'ils vivent au
sein de la famille sont abordés dans les
contes mais ils sont transposés dans un
monde merveilleux donc ça reste en même
temps la possibilité que ça reste pas
tout à fait eux et donc les messages
passent beaucoup mieux et
c'est ça travaille en profondeur sur sur
leurs difficultés et d'ailleurs pour
avoir cette distance on dit bien souvent
donc il y a le monde le monde
merveilleux mais on dit aussi il y a
très longtemps il était une fois donc ça
met cette distance et la fin en général
des contes merveilleux se termine bien
pourquoi bah parce que si on arrive à
résoudre ces difficultés c'est ça que ça
dit et bien on aura du bonheur et on est
en dehors de la morale et
de quelque chose de moraliste voilà
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup on
aime aussi enfin les compteurs de
Trappes les contes merveilleux voilà
autre question alors en dehors de ces
comptes vous parlez très bien je vais
lui dire que vous racontez un compte en
même temps que vous racontez c'est bien
fait du coup effectivement sans les
enfants Cécile de cette fête du conte il
y a des projets d'éducation artistique
qui sont alors qu'on a liés plus ou
moins malgré tout à cette manifestation
donc il y a des choses qui ont été
proposées depuis plusieurs années donc
notamment au niveau des maternelles et
primaires par le biais des comptes en
classe donc là en fait c'est des
bibliothécaires qui se déplacent dans
les classes pour aller compter aux
enfants directement et en particulier
aux classes qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité de venir dans les
médiathèques il y a une un atelier mon
tri qui a été proposé depuis plusieurs
années également au collégien de 6e 5e
donc là c'est un atelier montrer qui est
proposé par un compteur professionnel
qui s'appelle Etienne donc là on
travaille vraiment sur la définition
du de lamenterie mais également sur de
la production puisque c'est que les
collégiens se mettent en situation de
restituer sur une scène ouverte en fait
démontrer qu'ils ont eux qui se seront
appropriés en fait et la nouveauté de
cette année le troisième pont de cette
éducation artistique c'est des ateliers
qui ont été proposés en fait en écho à
au spectacle Cendrillon qui sera donné
au théâtre et donc là on a travaillé à
la fois avec un compteur professionnel
pour une classe avec une artiste
plasticienne pour une autre et là aussi
autour de ce thème là pour produire
quelque chose de nouveau avec les
enfants en fait qui s'approprient cette
histoire et qu'il la reste utile d'une
manière un petit peu différente merci
donc à vous deux d'être venu sur le
plateau dédicace que nous parler de
cette fête du conte qui se rappelle un
lieu du 22 novembre au 6 décembre 57
spectacle programmé on peut retrouver
toutes les informations sur le bandeau
qui a dû s'afficher en tout cas le site
internet du kiosque merci beaucoup à
vous deux d'être merci en plateau
une exposition de quatre artistes
céramistes céramistes pardon soutien
jusqu'au 13 décembre à la Galerie Le
Corbusier de Trappes quatre techniques
différentes sont proposées dont le
fameux Racou une technique japonaise
elle des images assignées William elle
de drôle de bêtes avec des antennes qui
peuvent faire penser à des mollusques ou
à autre chose aller place à
l'imagination avec Brigitte Lecointre
j'adore les objets j'adore les le monde
animal par sa beauté et j'ai envie un
petit peu de refaire sans pour cela
copier ce que ce qui était déjà fait
donc ça c'est mon monde à moi depuis 7
ans Brigitte Lecointre c'est spécialisé
dans le Racou une technique de cuisson
japonaise qui autorise bien des libertés
on fait une première cuisson qui
s'appelle le tesson à 1000 degrés et
lors de la deuxième cuisson qui sert
généralement à les maillage là on fait
une montée en température rapide on sort
la pièce à 1000 degrés donc il va avoir
un choc thermique et ensuite on va
l'enfumer donc c'est pour ça que ça
donne des effets noirs sur les parties
non émaillées parce que la terre
respaoreuse et absorbe le carbone et les
parties émaillées elles sont craquelées
parce que il y a ce choc thermique
Nani champi shot travaille à partir de
l'argile elle pratique également leur à
coup ces artistes plaisaientroisent
découvert la céramique lors d'atelier
d'arts plastiques c'était en Allemagne
elle avait 14 ans depuis elle n'a jamais
quitté la discipline aller au bout de la
matière c'est ce qu'elle aime tout
particulièrement elle présente ici des
formes très fines là par exemple faire
des formes aussi fines en terre c'est ça
va aller aux limites du matériau mais ça
m'intéresse de mettre des émaux que je
mets très épais qui donne des gouttes
ces craquelures ces retraits ça
m'intéresse à savoir faire que l'artiste
transmet aux jeunes générations à
travers des ateliers menés à la Galerie
Le Corbusier
j'ai vu quand j'ai donné la terre aux
enfants il y a un moment donné il y a
plus rien il y a plus en bruit ils font
et ça c'est de créer quelque chose qu'on
voit
je sais pas je peux pas expliquer plus
que ça que c'était vraiment pour moi un
choc deux autres artistes céramistes
exposent également leurs œuvres avec
d'autres techniques utilisées
fan lui travaille la poterie soit avec
un tour soit en modelage manuel et on
est plus dans du gré c'était terre qui
cuisent à 1200 degrés et pour terminer
dites le poivre elle travaille une toute
autre manière elle se sert vraiment de
la terre pour faire des sculptures au
sens classique du terme elle fait des
bustes elle fait des poissons très
amusants d'ailleurs très enfantin et
elle n'utilise pas du tout drakkou pas
du tout des mailles pas du tout d'oxyde
elle fait des patines
l'exposition se termine le 13 décembre
prochain et pour ceux qui veulent en
savoir un peu plus sur ces techniques de
la céramique la galerie Le Corbusier
propose des ateliers de sculpture tout
au long de l'année
et puis sachez que le vernissage de
l'exposition a lieu ce jeudi soir à
partir de 18h30 tout le monde est convié
c'est l'occasion justement de rencontrer
les artistes allez une autre exposition
qui démarre cette fois nos flux le
château une exposition de photographie
c'est jusqu'au 30 novembre 20
photographes professionnels et amateurs
présenteront 200 images inédites invités
d'honneur Yann Arthus-Bertrand également
Marie et Patrick Blin photographe du
célèbre Studio Harcourt et une autre
exposition consacrée cette fois ce n'est
pas courant bien aux mathématiques une
exposition qui promet mais oui de vous
faire aimer les maths via des
manipulations et des énigmes c'est avoir
à partir de 7 ans mais c'est également
réservé pour les adultes donc c'est à
partir du 22 novembre et jusqu'au 13
décembre à la Maison de l'Environnement
de Magny-les-Hameaux
cette semaine Nicolas Gervais a
rencontré Agathe iraséma chanteuse de
jazz d'origine brésilienne à l'énergie
débordante elle sera en concert à
l'estaminet de Magny-les-Hameaux
jeune chanteuse au talent certains elle
se produit avec son quartet jazz mais
également avec son brésilien musique
band avec lequel elle sera le 29
novembre allez staminet à
Magny-les-Hameaux voici à gatira sema
dans le kiosque
ma mère mon père sont des vrais
mélomanes mon père est musicien en plus
donc j'avais vraiment quelqu'un qui
pratiquait déjà la musique
quotidiennement la maison qui coûtait
beaucoup de choses donc j'écoutais aussi
bien des comptines pour les enfants que
Miles Davis que kaiton vélo ou plein
d'autres grands chanteurs brésiliens
que de la musique française enfin j'ai
vraiment pu écouter de tout quoi c'était
donc à mes 14 ans quand j'ai fait une
masterclass avec une chanteuse de jazz
qui s'appelle Chala Jordan qui est quand
même qui est un peu inscrit dans toute
la légende de l'histoire du jazz et
c'est vraiment elle qui m'a donné le feu
vert qui m'a dit que j'avais tout ce qui
est tout ce qu'il fallait pour faire ce
métier et ça fait un petit déclic et
puis j'ai la chance j'ai beaucoup de
gens enfin mes proches qui m'ont qui
m'ont soutenu dans cette envie et du
coup petit à petit on a réussi à mettre
en place un concert et puis de et puis
j'ai deux formations j'ai donc le cortex
de jazz qui est vraiment le premier
projet qui a vu le jour et de l'autre
côté il y a le brésilienne benne ces
deux projets qui
comptent pas vraiment été pensés comme
un binôme pas du tout mais ça se fait
écho ça se répond un peu le quartet
c'était au début vraiment dans la veine
traditionnelle jazz où j'ai essayé
d'apporter quelque chose d'un peu
moderne mais pas trop c'était plus dans
cette aspect un peu plus pop parce que
moi ce qui me plaisait dans le jazz
c'était le côté très populaire cette
musique très chaleureuse
j'aimais bien ce côté un peu tout fou du
jazz un peu un peu voilà très simple et
sourire donc j'essaie de d'avoir un
répertoire qui se construisait autour de
ça sur vraiment l'axe du swing
traditionnel et puis maintenant donc
voilà le projet évolué un petit peu là
on sort un nouvel album avec ce quartet
qui va sortir en février et c'est voilà
c'était déjà d'autres influences et des
influences un peu plus latines chantant
portugais j'ai composé aussi mon premier
morceau en portugais le vinyle qui vient
de sortir du AGA Jazz Quartet c'est
vraiment les morceaux qui ont bien
marché de ce premier projet avec le
Agadir scorset et qui n'ont pas été
enregistrés sur les pros sur les
derniers CD qu'on a fait donc c'est un
peu le vinyle c'est un peu la phase de
transition entre l'ancien projet de
quartet et ce nouvel album qui va sortir
très bientôt
à côté de ça il y a le Brasil and band
donc on sera avec le projet avec lequel
je serai le 29 à l'estaminet c'est
vraiment plein d'artistes différents qui
ont marqué qui m'ont qui m'ont touché et
qui qui m'ont vraiment marqué quand je
les ai découvert tout au long de mon
adolescence il y a plusieurs jours
musicaux différents c'était un peu
casse-coué ce projet parce qu'on à la
base c'était un projet qu'on a créé avec
tissus justement Rodriguez qui joue avec
nous à la batterie pour une ouverture de
Dam session donc l'assaut de thème
c'était la musique brésilienne et moi
j'ai ramené plein de chansons
différentes de plein d'artistes
différents d'époques différentes des
choses très additionnels des choses un
peu plus contemporaines
des choses plus ou moins connues et on a
réussi quand même à faire un répertoire
assez homogène avec avec tout ça
avec ce groupe en fait je balade un peu
le public dans plein d'univers
différents il y a des morceaux un peu
sans baroque des choses un peu plus
traditionnelles de bâillon des voilà des
musiques du nord-est du Brésil des
choses très contemporaines des
compositions originales de qui ont été
écrits par des membres de ma famille qui
jouent avec moi dans ce groupe bon moi
je chante la vie je chante l'amour
chante la colère
l'indignation enfin voilà toutes ces
choses enfin c'est vraiment le texte
même si je chante pas en français et que
je suis un champ pour un public français
le texte pour moi ça c'est quand même
très important je comprends ce que je
dis et c'est moi ce qui me touche dans
une chanson c'est vraiment ce que c'est
un peu cette pour moi une bonne chanson
c'est un peu comme une lettre ouverte
c'est un peu comme une vie qui défile
quelque part ou ou ma vie qui défile à
travers tous ces genres différents ça
finit toujours par quelque chose d'assez
festif dès qu'il y a un morceau qui s'y
prête j'invite les gens à danser à
chanter
et voici pour Agathe iraséma et elle
aussi Agathe the blues parfois mais
Agathe the power surtout on retrouve
Catherine
une autre soirée cette fois à la
batterie de Guyancourt avec le JFC big
bandes il y a 30 ans un orchestre
composé de 22 musiciens et de chanteurs
qui revitent la musique jazz c'est
samedi soir tu arrives à partir de 6 € à
l'extrait
et puis toujours à la batterie de
Guyancourt mais cette fois c'est
vendredi soir du rock du Sou du funk
avec Amina Attal et Nicky Hill la
nouvelle sensation rock'n'roll des
États-Unis Nina Attal elle compte à ce
jour 300 concerts elle a 22 ans elle a
déjà 6 ans d'expérience derrière elle on
va l'écouter tarif à partir de 9 euros
et tout autre ambiance maintenant avec
la fille du tambour majeur l'opéra de
funkback en 3 actes proposés par le
petit théâtre lyrics et samedi dimanche
à l'espace de Coville de Voisins le
bretonneux tarif à partir de 8 euros
comme tous les mercredis la chronique
cinéphile et ont démarré évidemment avec
les avis de spectateurs
c'est un film sur l'identité donc c'est
toujours un thème qui est intéressant je
j'étais aussi
j'aime beaucoup le l'acteur aussi
Mathieu Kassovitz mais j'ai eu du mal à
rentrer dans le fil il y a une idée mais
la réalisation n'est pas convaincante
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce film en fait c'est
très hitch coquillant en termes de
suspense d'une part mais aussi et toute
une réflexion sur la paternité sur
l'identité sur soi-même dans la foule et
l'anonymat et la personnalité en même
temps c'est pas mal
je suis pas spécialement une fan de
Hunger Games mais vraiment le film était
bien et puis ça donne envie pour la
suite le parc la partie 2 très bon film
j'ai regardé le 1 et 2 la semaine
dernière pour me remettre dans
l'ambiance et franchement j'ai été
impressionné on est
il joue un peu avec nos émotions le
producteur et donc on est tenu jusqu'à
la fin vraiment jusqu'à la fin du film
et très bon film à aller voir
le coup de coeur m'attend d'un
professionnel
cette semaine le coup de cœur de
l'espace Philippe noir et le film
d'animation boxtrolls l'action se
déroule à cheesebridge une ville huppée
de l'époque victorienne dont la
principale préoccupation et le luxe la
distinction et la crème des fromages les
plus pures sous le charme de cérup pavés
se cache des boxtrolls d'horrible
monstre qui rampe hors des égouts la
nuit pour dérober ce que les habitants
ont de plus cher leurs enfants et leurs
fromages enfin c'est du moins ce que dit
la légende adapter d'un compte pour
enfants ce film d'animation est un
véritable dépaysement empreint d'humour
de poésie de valeurs humaniste et
quelques moments d'anthologie on notera
tout particulièrement la beauté des
décors miniatures des boxtrolls est une
merveille de précision et constitue une
vraie prouesse visuelle esthétiquement
ce film est très réussi il touchera sans
aucun doute petits et grands boxtroll
est à découvrir en famille cette semaine
à l'espace Philippe Morel ce que leur
vie seront menacées
on se laisse capturer on réagit même pas
ils trouveront de l'aide
là où il s'y attendent là
il faudra que tu fasses exactement ce
que je dis pour commencer on laisse ta
boîte
allez une autre info cinéma la
projection du film we want sex egalité
vendredi soir à la boutique de quartier
de Magny-les-Hameaux la projection sera
suivie d'ailleurs d'un débat ce film
traite de la première grève des
ouvrières d'une usine forte pour obtenir
leur obtention d'une complète égalité
salariale homme femme c'est évidemment
toujours d'actualité
pour cette semaine rendez-vous mercredi
prochain même endroit même heure toutes
les informations culturelles évidemment
à retrouver sur le site internet du
kiosque je vous souhaite une excellente
semaine bonne soirée